blessings on grass
thank you thanks very much for the
introduction and for the kind invitation
also uh as jim has pointed out you know
i'm actually not here for the
spectrograph theory program so i'm
actually a bit out of my dap here
nonetheless you know i hope what i
talked about would be of a little bit of
interest to you so uh
yeah so the motivation really is uh well
by the way i should thank cheyenne and
ron uh some of this book i'll join with
them and uh i learned a lot from
discussions with them
so you know the uh so what i'm going to
talk about essentially it's about how
you can
uh
you can uh do spectrograph theory
uh when
when the norm is not a tunnel okay so
spectrograph theory well if you
view it in a certain way right like what
uh what i have on the slide is that you
look at the graph laplacian and you look
at the rayleigh quotient of the graph
laplacian
and of course the
norm that you use in the denominator of
the graph laplacian that is a two norm
and the uh bilinear form on top well
it's bilinear or quadratic so it's a two
tensor you're
the graph laplacian you're viewing it as
a two tensor it's uh it takes a pair of
uh
functions on graph to scala so it's a
two tensor and uh this talk we're going
to be talking about a case where the
norm is
something other than a two not a p
naught okay and where the tensor is
something other than the two tensor so
we're gonna look at uh like
laplacians defined on on alternating
detentions we're gonna we're we're gonna
look at uh laplacians on uh hyper graphs
which would not be a two tensor okay so
and uh basically that's uh what we're
gonna talk about today it's gonna be a
very light talk this is uh
the last talk and probably the i think
the only talk in the afternoon so
i'm just gonna
well entertain you amuse you a little
bit hopefully and uh we can all go for
uh well dinner afterwards well maybe not
even then for t okay yeah so the thing
is why why is two so prevalent why is it
uh well the de facto norm and the de
facto order of the tensor when you talk
about spectrograph theory so partly it's
due to this observation by gene lawler
so gene lawler was a professor here at
berkeley uh
many years ago and he likes to talk
about this thing the mystical power of
twoness so in fact when he passed away
there was a memorial volume
and the title for that i guess or maybe
one of the article in that written by uh
lenstra it's
precisely the mystical power of twoness
so he made the observation of course the
sum of this observation that many
problems in computer science are easy if
you have two right two coloring is easy
okay three coloring is hard right as
soon as you change from two it becomes
difficult two-dimensional matching is
easy three-dimensional matching is hard
so of course heart can mean mp hot or it
can mean something else right so if you
talk about physics you have two body
problem and three body problems one is
easy the other one is hot so likewise
for easing model well
and uh in statistics actually i just
learned this from charlene last night uh
if you look at the james stein estimator
again the the phenomenon arises when you
go from two to three right and today
we're going to talk about two norm and
three now okay so of course why do you
use the two norm two norm is easy to
compute right if you do like three norm
or in fact uh any norm that's not one to
infinity that is going to be mp hard and
likewise you know i uh you know my
favorite example is that if you look at
matrix problem right two tensor problems
in some sense they are all easy right
polynomial time algorithm you have you
can bound errors you can bounce
accuracies you know you understand a lot
about them but once you go from two to
three it becomes uh difficult okay
right so however why should we look at
uh
instances when it's not two okay well so
of course you know the computational
intractability is going to be an
obstacle but we are not going to look at
uh things just from the perspective of
computational tractability of course i
understand that's primarily the use of
spectrograph theory
uh
sometimes you can you can get insights
okay
and uh when even if something is not uh
it's not tractable computational okay so
and that is uh the point that i would
like to make here so uh let me give you
two examples okay one from each of this
uh program the first one from the
spectral graph theory program the
trigger constant of a graph
so the cheetah constant of the graph
well uh i guess
is the number of cards like you break a
graph out into two pieces
uh to partition into two pieces and you
look at the number of uh edges that run
from one to the other and you divide by
the minimum of the volume of each of
this piece and you look at this minimum
over all possible partition of the graph
okay v is the vertex set of the graph
now this is very well known right first
studied in differential geometry by
chiga and i bet you have seen it like 50
times in this uh
this week's program okay or maybe like
even in in previous weeks program so
this is uh i would say you know it's
probably fair to say that this is a
central object of interest in the
spectrograph theory program
and uh well what about the other program
the one i'm participating in in the
algebraic geometry program well one of
the main objects okay is something
called a permanent okay the permanent is
a
well even
if you're not in the even if you're in a
spectrograph theory program you would
have heard of the permanent okay one
reason is that this is a one of the
great uh one of the most successful use
of spectral graph theory is to
estimate the uh
approximate the value of a permanent on
a zero one matrix where the oh sorry uh
stochastic matrix that's uh the result
of uh one of our
uh a direct co-director of this uh
institute okay so uh the permanent of
course is a um notoriously difficult uh
object in multiple sense right
it belongs to some of the hardest
complexity classes
and of course it's also of a main
interest in this it has rich geometry
okay and
and it's one of the main object of
interest in the other program the
algebraic geometry program now the thing
is uh
so i'm going to try to say say why is it
that it it pays to look at norms other
than two norms and why does it pay to
look at uh
laplacian
operators other than
those there are two tenses okay
so
let's look at the first one
so one major use of the uh chiga in
chiga constant is that it appears in
something called the uh chigas
inequality okay
well in in differential geometry the
chiga constant this hg or trigger number
is used to understand the second
uh
eigenvalue of the uh well the
la plus belgium operator on the manifold
okay the plastic
manifold in spectrograph theory is used
in the opposite way okay people are not
interested in the the second eigenvalue
of the laplacian what you're interested
in is in fact the chiga constant itself
so they use this to study the but it's
uh mp hard to compute so they use
they use this relation the cheetah
inequality to to study to approximately
trigger uh constant okay so it's bound
between
uh well two simple functions of the
second eigenvalue of your graph
laplacian well the thing is because this
is a very nice inequality it's used for
one for example to to it's used to to
approximate the permanent right however
it's an inequality so it's not so nice
right you know i ideally you know i
prefer equality so what if i insist that
i have to write the cheetah constant as
an equality right now
with some eigenvalue in fact you know if
you uh
if you work really hard you can actually
show that uh the shigeru constant is the
second
eigenvalue of the one laplacian okay
and this is uh actually proof recently a
lot of people i guess suspected this or
maybe it's already known but uh you know
what i i learned this from casey chang
when i was in uh china earlier this
summer
so this is uh well i'll say this is very
interesting right you know you can
actually say that the trigger constant
is an eigenvalue and not just bounded
between two eigenvalues two functions of
eigenvalues okay so uh what is here so
here's an example where the one
laplacian appears okay the one laplacian
is the laplacian
uh with respect to in some sense uh the
uh
well so i should say maybe this uh these
are called non-linear laplacian on many
foes they are very well known okay the p
laplacian is the divergence of the
the
norm of the gradient f raised to p minus
two power times gradient of f okay
that's the formula over there all right
i guess
and uh
so
when p is equal to one that becomes a
well actually a quantity that's
non-differentiable right so what uh
this is the manifold version is very
very well known so what casey chang is
to did was to extend it to graph okay in
particular the one laplacian graph so
it's uh if you take the co boundary
operator something that we're going to
define later that's the etch vertex
incidence matrix
uh and you compute this thing okay of a
function okay take the matrix it
represents the code boundary operator if
you take the b
transpose b that gives you the graph
laplacian but if you take b transpose
times the sine of b f okay this sine is
your
well the sine function okay the
derivative of your of your absolute
value function and it's going to give
you the uh
one laplacian on a graph so the
uh trigger constant is equals precisely
to the second eigenvalue of this
laplacian so i think that
may not be useful that just says that
this is hard to compute right in in a
well if you want to view it from the
perspective of how people usually use
spectral graph theory however it's
insightful okay so i know that achieve
the constant really is some uh
eigenvalues
yeah that's a very good question so of
course the thing is uh one of the main
theme that i'm going to talk about in
this uh in this lecture is that
eigenvalues of course is defined for
linear operators right so this is
obviously non-linear or the p laplacian
obviously it's not linear so how do you
even talk about eigenvalues so what i
meant is a
eigenvalue in a sense of what uh people
in pde okay like that's the folks who
will study peel of classroom would do or
people in optimization theory what are
what are eigenvalues eigenvalues are
lagrange multipliers and view from that
perspective you can define you know in
fact later on we'll see it we can define
eigenvalues for all kinds of stuff okay
including non-linear operators including
tensors and things like this okay
let's play a little bit more with this
the sign this is the
uh so
it's uh yeah so the sign of a function
this is of course non-differentiable
optimization what is the sign of a func
a a number the sign of a number t is
going to be
-1
if t is of course negative it's going to
be plus 1 if t is
positive and it's going to be a interval
minus 1 to 1 if t is 0. so this is a set
value function okay
it's uh not a function in the usual
sense is not a number no
it's going to be a set so that is why
it's so
you know that's why people didn't didn't
predict the definition
this is sort of the right definition if
you if you want to if you want
sort of the second eigenvalue to be
equals to the chiga uh constant then
this has to be the one okay that's why
you may i mean
you don't have a different motivation
for this this i mean
so of course it's also
something it's trivial once you define
this that this thing on that this thing
on the side sure sure sure that's right
that's right yeah just for this purpose
or yeah i i guess the thing is uh you
know there's a
so the uh
so i'm not exactly sure it's true okay
i haven't quite digest the paper yet i
i'm happy to show it to you later the
author has sent me a preprint
yeah
i mean i think it's okay yeah okay so
but anyway this is
this is not going to be that way so
component twice
component-wise component-wise of course
yeah you do it component-wise if it's a
vector yes
for that result can you also say
something about the cheater cut and the
eigenvector
the
the cheater cut to the eigenvector oh
okay uh so the thing is uh that
yeah so
well the thing is i have to
i have to get back to you on that that i
do not know okay yeah but anyway you
know this is
mean to be meant to be a motivation
right so this is motivation for the
spectrograph theory folks
has meanings in terms of higher
dimensions which you're not using right
so because i understand one laplacian
from the last talk was something to do
okay so the thing is i'm going to use
the word one laplacian in multiple ways
so this is the non-linear one laplacian
and later i'm going to talk about the
horse one laplacian okay that's the one
that we use in uh later on okay and
that's the second part that's going to
be when i start
formally study talk this is sort of just
motivation and well uh another example
right for the algebraic geometry folks
right uh well maybe it's
it's not
a question that you would naturally ask
but let's say we ask this question
well so the permanent is of course a
homogeneous polynomial uh degree n and n
square variables right the entries of
your matrix so in that sense it's a
that's equivalent to saying that it's a
symmetric n tensor a tensor of order n
so you can write down in coordinates as
a hyper matrix okay so it's a n squared
by n squared by n squared okay n times
uh matrix
and the uh well sort of thing is the
because of the fact we we wanted to make
sure that it's symmetric the entries are
uh you know it's non-zero i guess this
constant when it's uh
when the uh when you have uh that
property when the indices are precisely
equals to one of the uh terms that
occurs in uh monomial okay so the point
uh well you may or may not know this but
you know symmetric tenses have
eigenvalues right and it's defined
precisely in a way that and i explained
to andrea so this is uh i will say we'll
look at this later but just take it on
fave right now so eigen values as i said
are lagrange multipliers so in that
sense symmetric tensors have eigenvalues
uh so uh
so what are the eigenvalues of this very
important object right what is what are
the eigenvalues of the permanent when
you view it as a symmetric tensor okay
now the thing is that it would appear to
be a pretty daunting problem however if
you can use graph theory well and graph
laplacian
or rather hypergraph laplacian then you
can actually solve this quite easily you
can find all the eigen values again you
can view the permanent tensor as the
adjacency tensor just like you have a
graph here that is json c matrix you
have a hyper graph you have adjacency
tensor essentially it's a n-dimensional
matrix with ones whenever you have hyper
edges and zero elsewhere now the thing
is uh the eigenvalues of well you can
make some observation and use those
observations to find the eigenvalues of
this permanent tensors okay it's a joint
work with shangrang who my postdoc
yeah so the thing is uh the largest one
is going to be essentially the
spectral knob right that's uh
they are
you can count them it's an interesting
problem in algebraic geometry uh giorgio
ottaviani has done some very significant
work in this regard so it's uh sort of
it the way i would say it is that it
enhances your your your understanding of
matrices okay so like uh you can talk
about characteristic polynomials
yeah
uh-huh well so i do not know of any
actual use okay but i i do know that it
gives you some insights okay so like uh
you know you can ask various questions
what's the analog of a characteristic
polynomial how is it related to for
example the hyperdeterminant and stuff
like this
yeah so the first part is
uh well this part actually has two parts
that uh part that you just heard was
part zero motivation the first part is
about hodgson plus and it's uh sort of a
in uh and uh just uh providing uh sort
of some easy aspect of uh of shigen's
talk early on in the day so um let me
tell you about
porch laplacians and co-homology
uh but in a well really really simple
way okay so this is going to be the
simplest uh well i should say that it
came from a
came from this uh
this uh lecture that i gave at the
uh thanks to cheyenne right at the
meeting where i'm supposed to explain
like
discount things to to people with no
background at all okay and a sort of
scientific american level okay and uh
this is uh the result of that so i hope
it would interest you or amuse you a
little bit okay now what is homology
okay this is chromology in one slide i
challenge you to find something that's
easier than this okay now the thing is
uh let's
suppose that we have two matrices i'm
not gonna tell you what they are let's
just say two matrices
uh
m by n m by p so we can take their
product and let's say the product is
zero okay
so this is well
freshman lenny algebra well maybe even
high school in the algebra that if you
have this relation that if the product
of two matrices is zero
uh then the image of one must be
included in the kernel of the next one
right the image of b must be included in
a column of a right otherwise a b cannot
be zero
right and the thing is uh in fact this
is even only f and since these are
subspaces you can say that image of b is
a subspace of the turn of a and what is
called homology homology is the kind of
a quotient image of b okay just the
quotient space of
a vector space by its subspace okay this
is homology okay homology
exactly the same except that you have
different a and b okay
now next thing is horse theory okay
again in one slide what is hot theory
okay
essentially there's another way to do it
okay if you don't like quotient space
which i don't right because cushion
space means you have to deal with
elements that are equivalent classes so
it's sort of hard to represent them
right if you want to do computations
with them so can i find an actual
element
uh
and well a vector instead of a of us
equivalence class or practice well it
turns out that you can okay so
so and the way is to use uh the horse
laplacian right harsh laplacians to take
the two matrices that we had previously
a and b
where a b is equal to zero and from this
uh from this uh
this product okay this is the hot
laplacian that uh charge was talking
about uh earlier so it's a star a right
is a star is the edge of a well you
realize that it can be formed
well it makes sense right you know this
is going to be a n by n matrix now the
kernel of this the kernel of this matrix
the null space is precisely the code
molecule so i could have defined coral g
to be the noun space of this hodgs
laplacian okay
well and furthermore it gives you
insights you know there's something
called horse decomposition uh we'll see
this again later it says that the uh
the space or the domain of a or if you
like um
sorry the the
the co domain of b can be decomposed
into an orthogonal decomposition every
vector in cn can be written as a sum of
three vectors each orthogonal to the
others
and furthermore the piece in the middle
the co homology the kind of a star a
plus bb star is the intersection of the
kernels of a and b star okay very very
simple everything can be you can give
this as an exercise to to to your
undergraduate uh linear and your
undergraduate linear algebra class in
fact i do that okay so
now the thing is uh of course something
that's so simple you know it's hard to
impress people so you have to come up
with big names for all these objects
okay
so that's essentially what algebraic
topology is to
give names to this stuff okay the
matrices a and b are called cobalt
remaps okay elements of cn you call them
code chains right and when you have the
map like this you call it cochine
complex like cycles boundaries are the
elements of kind of a animation b and
respectively and you can say that uh an
element of uh turn off a co-cycle is
called closed uh e element of a co co
boundary is co-exact right it's the last
two relation uh chromology classes you
can either view them as uh
the well elements of the quotient space
right
a quotient kernel like image b or we can
view them as harmonic chord chains okay
that means view them as elements of the
color of the hodge laplacian the body
number of course is just a dimension of
either one of this spaces okay so that
is
algebraic topology okay
well so the thing is of course this is
spectral graph theory so let's see how
this is relevant to
uh
to uh well
two graphs okay
so
of course i didn't tell you you know one
thing that i laugh out is what are a and
b right so of course it's not true for
any two matrices a and b where the
product is zero right it has to be some
the uh topologies are interested in
specific a and b right they have many
many different different ways to define
this matrices a and b
and you know this sort of uh this gadget
that i talk about here right this uh
construction here gives you homology
classes okay now uh
so let's look at graphs and see how this
is relevant to graphs okay and then
so the uh and of course you know you
heard charlie's talk early on and this
is
exactly what he was talking about
uh early on so uh let's say we have
graphs okay so graph is
every graph gives you a simple show
complex okay so what is that that means
if i have a well graph usually it's
built off of vertices like zero
dimensional simplex right that's a scary
word that uh uh well topologies come out
for the disease and one some simplices
right that's edges and again what that
topologies use to call edges and there
are triangles or three clicks but that's
called two sim simplex so the thing is a
simpler complex is something that you
can build out of uh objects like this
where you glue simplices along faces
okay so that's the symptom complex so
every graph gives you some partial
complex every con symptom complex gives
you a graph right
uh how's that you know it's very simple
if i give you a graph or all i do is i
fill in all the clicks okay then get
that gives me a simplistic complex right
for instance if i have a triple vertices
and there are edges all around i fill in
that right that's a three click right
it's a triangle so i fill in i assume
that it's a triangle there if i have
four of them four four
four vertices that forms a complete sub
graph i feel in that tetrahedron so that
becomes a simplistic complex and
likewise given a simplistic complex i
just remove all the simplices of uh all
the interior of simplices of uh
dimension higher than two and i get a
graph so it's one to one okay so graphs
and some special complexes are
essentially the same okay
at least in this in this picture right
now
so uh
uh so i'm gonna call kg the uh this sort
of uh it's a dissimilar complex it's
called the click complex
and
what i'm gonna say next is gonna be uh
so this is just you i haven't related to
what i was talking about earlier so
now what are
so what are your code chains right
remember that the functions in the
elements in cn are called code chains
right
we have here right code chains is just a
term for the elements of cn but what is
cn okay so
here's what a c and c of course is a
vector space right you know if i don't
choose bases i can make it abstract so
these are all my possible choices for c
n i can look at the functions on
vertices i can look at the functions on
edges i can look at the functions on
triangles okay of course can go higher
we'll come to that later but let's start
from one two and three right
uh so uh i'm gonna look at special types
of functions right uh because i want my
edges undirected so i want my my
functions on edges to be well it's gonna
be a
you know function on a pair of vertices
but since you know my graph is
undirected i'm just going to decree that
the value of i j is equal to negative a
value of j i okay this is an alternating
matrix okay uh skew symmetric matrix
well how about the uh
functions on triangles again that's a
function on triples or vertices and
again i'm going to require it has this
alternating property when i do it all
permutation it's going to change the
size going to change according to the
sign of the permutation okay this is a
skew symmetric pre-tensor okay when
physics right so that's uh these are
just the you know i can view this as
potential on electric view right uh or a
tensorflow right on on the
space and topology they're just called
zero one two code chains okay so those
are the elements that your matrices a
and b act on right of course you know
since these are finite dimensional it's
automatically the space of this zero
code chains or one code chains or two
code chains is gonna be c n for some n
okay oh okay uh i use real here right so
if i use complex numbers then it would
be c right but let's say real let's move
to real from now on so what are the cool
boundary operators what are the a and b
that we talked about at the beginning so
in topology again they have uh
special choices for a and b right so uh
i'm gonna use uh
freshman calculus language instead of uh
you know topology language so
core boundary operators essentially are
finite
difference operators okay discrete
derivative so the gradient of
a function right on a
on a on the vertices is going to be a
function on the edges okay and that
function is given by simply taking
the function on the let's say s is your
function on your
on your vertices and i'm just going to
take pairwise uh difference of that so
that is gradient okay it takes
0 code chain to one code chain if you
like okay
and i put l2 just because you know
there's an inner product so i'm just uh
if i write i should write c c zero
uh k okay but you know let's let's be
uh likewise you can talk about uh the
next
derivative that takes what
a is b is my graph a is my code okay
and uh so a times b cograp you know that
that is going to give you zero right so
that is a very nice
so this is this gives you candidates for
your matrices a and b right because
close of grad is zero you can also
define things like divergence right we
need something when we talk about horse
decomposition we needed something called
uh the adjoin of uh
of uh you know our a and b right so the
edge drawing of a gradient is going to
be something called divergence and it's
denoted diff okay so great difficult as
sort of a
well i guess one of the most some of the
most basic objects that you learn in in
vector calculus so
this uh what just
exactly just basic stuff but the graph
laplacian right in this sense is just
the uh the
diff composed of the graph okay the uh
if you like b b uh b star b right
and if you look at the next uh well the
one
uh hodge la passion okay the the sort of
the next order the next object that's
above the graph laplacian in this
picture that is what i would call the
helmholtz operator what people normally
call the helmholtz operator and what is
that that in this notation is language
is negative graph div plus coe join co
okay
so this is uh
so this is uh so we know for example
from that first two slides on topology
that the kernel of uh
of uh uh
of delta one is going to give you your
one cohomology kernel delta zero is
going to give you your zero uh homology
okay so
now the thing is uh what about higher up
so higher you know the thing is uh i
have to bring in some topology language
so you can look at alternating functions
on any uh
k dimensional uh simplices okay and
these are called k-chord chains and
likewise you can define uh you can
define co boundary operators on this i'm
gonna i can put inner products on this
cochain complex that's why i write l2
and the boundary operators is defined
precisely by an alternating sum so if
you look at the special case k equals
zero one and two you get the your your
operators great and diff okay ah sorry
great and co okay
well so the fundamental theorem topology
and that is the first equation i've i've
introduced in this part of the lecture
that's a b equals to zero you take two
matrices and the product is equal to
zero okay that is in some sense the
fundamental theorem topology okay it
says that the boundary of a boundary is
now okay if you take any imagine any any
geometric object okay look at this
boundary and look at the boundary of the
boundary you see that it's going to be
an empty set okay this is sort of the
the opposite this uh the dual of that it
says the co boundary of a code boundary
is equal to zero okay and once you have
this as we saw earlier it merely allows
you to do uh all this stuff okay define
hormone g to find hot laplacian and
things like this and this is exactly
what
we do right so
uh the next thing is to
uh well follow what we did earlier but
and now in an abstract framework with
this you can define the combinatorial
hotspot parsing okay and this is uh
what uh you know cheyenne was talking
about earlier
and the
chromology process would uh you know uh
precisely the kernel of this as we saw
earlier so those are called harmonic
forms so again it's a harmonic homology
cycles this is nice because you have an
actual function on your
synthesis or a vector that
that represents your chromoly classes
instead of a of a whole equivalence
classes of that and there's a heart
decomposition theorem just like what i
said earlier except that this is now
rewritten in this slightly more abstract
language okay and this can be easily
proved using simple linear algebra okay
uh the taste of greatest interest right
for application which i won't talk about
today uh because i guess uh
ron might say a few words about this
tomorrow so i want to say more about
this
so it's the case where k is equals to
one okay when you look at
functions on pairs of vertices or
functions on on edges now the thing is
this helmholtz decomposition or horse
decomposition for k equals one is
actually useful okay you can use it to
study problems in ranking run
aggregation or you can use it to study
uh problems in game theory which uh
pablo did in this wonderful paper okay
so uh
so this is uh stuff i won't go into and
anyway both of uh these some of the
authors are here pablo is here and john
is here you can just ask them
right so what about relevance to this
workshop so i know that of course you
know this workshop people are interested
in using spectrograph theory to solve
all kinds of difficult problems like for
example you want to solve a linear
system
or linear programming problems in in
in time that is that is better than what
is currently known of course you know
the other workshop the algebraic
geometry workshop is also interested in
this problem how do you invert a matrix
in time says o n 2 plus epsilon well
they of course that's
slightly
of a slightly different flavor okay this
workshop is interested in how to use
spectrograph theory to do and how can i
invert a matrix or solve a x equals b in
a either exact or least square sense
uh by exploiting you know
ideas from spectral graph theory and
doing it in nearly linear time okay
well so of course this is uh this
uh the amazing work of spielman and tang
and
uh well lots of other people have uh
done work since then by any way these
are probably the origins well so how is
it
relevant well so
well one thing is that if you look at uh
this notion called uh reaching curvature
okay you're given a
a sim simplicial complex or actually a
graph you can define something called
the rigid curvature okay
now uh oh by the way if you're saying
that you know one of the
one of the uh i guess one of the key
ideas in this spearman tang approach is
that
when whenever you have a whenever you
have a diagonally dominant symmetric
matrix okay you can view it sort of as a
graphical position and using this you
know you sort of could uh you know use
spectrograph theory ideas to solve to
invert that matrix in in almost linear
time but so the thing is how about high
order laplacian okay so
the relation is that well let's say i
want to do this for high order laplacian
of course what what do you gain by
looking at higher order laplacian right
you know
first of all graph laplacian must always
be the usual zero roughly graphic
buzzing must always be
a positive semi-definite matrix but high
order roughly position actually removes
that okay you no longer have that
requirement any matrix if essentially i
guess you can represent it as some
higher autograph will pass it so you can
do this for high order graphical buzzing
you could actually invert any matrix not
just symmetric diagonally dominant
matrix in nearly linear time okay so one
example when this is possible is when
the reaching curvature is positive okay
when the reader is non-negative when a
region curvature is not negative you can
actually do this but that of course
relies on the result of spearman and
tank right because when the reaching
curvature is non-negative
delta one is actually diagonally
dominant and symmetric i'll get this out
and you know this is sort of ongoing
work that i'm talking about with yuan
and cheyenne so but right now this is
all i can say what if the region
coverage is not
positive okay that's the actually the
interesting case that would be the case
that's not covered by schmann and tang
okay
second part you know uh
hypergraphs okay this is the part where
i talk about the permanent unfortunately
um
unfortunately i didn't have time to
finish this part okay so i only have uh
i would tell you a few things right uh
but i won't be able to get to the
permanent thing okay so this is a
current uh joint work with a post doc uh
shanghai
i mentioned earlier right so uh this is
sort of a bit different but still the
the element is the the the base element
is actually uh the graph laplacian okay
and its eigenvalues just like uh before
uh so well if you have a symmetric
matrix this is where i'm going to talk
about defining eigenvalues when you
don't have a linear operator
so of course you have a matrix you can
view the
symmetric matrix you can view the
eigenvalues and eigenvectors of as the
critical values and critical points of
your rayleigh quotient okay
well or equivalently you can view it as
say lagrange multipliers you know uh you
can write down the lagrangian for this
problem and say that you want to
constrain the denominator to unit norm
okay and unit norm in the sense of the
l2 not again the two not not
so if you write down the lagrangian and
you write down the kkt condition you're
going to get your usual eigenvalue
eigenvector equation okay this one here
and what are your critical uh
lagrange multiplier those are precisely
your eigenvalues okay so the moral here
is the eigenvalues are lagrange
multipliers and this is sort of a pretty
well-known thing right if you study
non-linear eigenvalues in in in pde
that's that's exactly how they view uh
eigen what what they mean by
non-linear eigenvalues now
so this also allows you to do it for
tensors okay this is non-linear okay the
tensor is uh so i'm going to use the
word tensor a bit loosely what i meant
is a tensor with coordinates a proper
term would be hyper matrices so this can
be done for uh
hyphen matrix okay treat
m by m by n three dimensional matrix
that is symmetric again meaning that
aijk doesn't depend on the uh the
indices ijk you can permute in any order
and it would give you the same
value now you can look at the cubic
rayleigh quotient take a cubic form
right define on the
in the numerator of this thing and
divide by
and normalize it okay by the l3 norm so
to speak okay well so there's uh of
course you know here's where you start
to have a bit of ambiguity right so the
l3 norm if i put absolute value that's
exactly the l3 norm that's nice
uh well you know except that it won't be
algebraic okay so it's uh so the thing
is is if you put absolute value the
techniques of algebraic geometry
wouldn't apply to this anymore you
cannot use that to study and if you want
to use that to study right like what
luke and what jojo did this problem you
have to use the algebraic l3 not meaning
you leave out the absolute value let's
do that for now right you know actually
both are useful in in different ways
uh actually you can use the l2 norm as
well but uh i won't get into that so the
l3 norm this gives you a sort of uh
something a scale independent right if
you you have a ratio of something cubic
to something cubic so your lagrange
multipliers and your eigenvalues are
going to be scale uh independent so this
is nice in that sense okay but l2 norm
is nice for other other things if you
look at the you carry out the same thing
right look at the kkt condition of this
uh constrain optimization problem
uh the it's gonna give you an equation
that looks very much that's sort of the
the analog of your eigenvalue
eigenvector equation except that now
it's going to be a quadratic system
rather than a linear system okay
now is this
i mean because what giorgio and luke do
is coordinate independent yeah but you
said yours is coordinate dependent uh
yeah so the thing is for example this
would not be preserved by uh so i guess
what giorgio did was to look at the
eigenvector okay
so that can be written down in a
coordinated independent way right no no
but we use the norm
yes does that true you you define the
same function
for l to not that's right
yeah yeah so well as i said you know
when you
when you go from two to three suddenly
things becomes more complicated you're
gonna go from a two tensor matrix to
three tensor a hyper matrix suddenly
things becomes ambiguous
uh you know there's really like uh you
can use l2 norm you get something
interesting you can use l3 norm you get
something interesting too like for
instance using this notion i can prove
uh i can prove a prone forbids theorem
for three-dimensional in fact
k-dimensional hyper-matrices right if
these are non-negative matrices there's
a parotropinist theorem it's exactly
like the one that you proved from matrix
again that's using this this l3 knob if
you use l2 norm you can get something
else right for instance uh uh i would
say uh uh that loop and jojo has this
amazing paper that actually uses this
concept to find tensor decomposition
which is
only for our real numbers
it's over complex okay so yeah so of
course you know that if you have a real
a symmetric matrix the eigenvalues are
real that you lose that right as i said
you go from two to three it becomes
harder so
you lose that property when you go to a
hyper matrix so when you have a a high
order tensor it's eigenvalues even if
it's symmetric the eigenvalues can be
complex okay
so how does this apply to graph theory
of course right so
uh last couple minutes i'm going to talk
about this so we it it doesn't okay but
it applies to hypergraph theory okay so
if i have a hyper graph that's a
generalization of a graph instead of uh
we have vertices as usual but instead of
uh
of edges we talk about hyper edges okay
so there's a collection of k k element
subsets of v
and it's undirected so i don't care
about the order now so a hyper graph is
called uh okay i'm not going to need
this well actually i'm not going to talk
about the the next part is it's not
going to be useful too because i won't
get to that okay so but anyway there's
this notion of a k-pop type k hyper
graph where you can partition things
into
into uh
k vertices where each edge
intersects only with one of this
partition set with one this vi okay
that's called it's just like a bipartite
graph or a two colorable graph now the
thing is this kind of uh
why why is this of interest this is of
interest because the permanent answer is
k-pop i okay and this is the relation we
use to find its eigenvalue but i i won't
get to that i'm out of time and i don't
actually have the slides okay
okay so uh the adjacency tensor or the
hyper matrix is going to be
well you know if i give you the name and
i tell you what an adjacency matrix of
graph is you would come up with this
definition right so it's going to be a
symmetric uh tensor m by n by n if it's
a 3
graph
where it's a the value is one aijk is
one if that edge is there it's just an
indicator function of whether and and
hyper edge is present in the hyper graph
okay and of course each one this uh
hyper matrix is going to define a cubic
form okay i write a aff so this cubic
form divided so this cubic form divided
by that sum of the f i okay or
constrained to the
l3 sphere where the the algebraic l3
sphere
is going to give you your eigenvalues
okay reminder from the last slide now so
why why is this useful okay this is
useful because instantly you can prove
some very
basic result that parallels what you
have in spectrograph theory okay
nope
nope
final museum yeah yeah so this is not a
norm as i said okay this thing can be
zero okay so they can
yeah that's why it's not it's uh but so
if you put absolute value okay
then you get compactness if you
then but it becomes non-algebraic it's
not a point you cannot study using uh
element geometry anymore but if you
don't put absolute value then it becomes
non-compatible to the upsides that you
can use algebraic geometry in the
definition of l3 you do need that yes
yes of course of course right so yeah
that's that's why you know when it's odd
order actually it departs from uh when
it's even older and real it's fine but
when it becomes complex or anything then
this actually
even the l2 norm whenever you have sum
of squares instead of sum of absolute
value of squares things becomes
different okay
so but let me not get into that so you
know well these are uh things that you
can prove well in fact i thought i
proved them and then i realized that you
know
a few years later when i was giving a
talk that uh you know this actually uh
the
uh this uh joel friedman and uh
vickerson actually had almost the same
thing okay almost the same thing in a
paper that's published long long ago
okay so so it tells you in some sense
that this eigenvalues this eigenvalues
that i define or you may not believe
that this is the right way to define
eigenvalues why should i use the l3 norm
and or the l2 normal should i not use
the the uh absolute value well the thing
is it gives you uh results like this
okay so as far as spectrograph theory or
spectral hypergraph theory is concerned
this is sort of right okay
now the thing is uh
so uh well so this is the part that i
would not have time to finish okay so
this is uh the part that would be
related to
to the permanent so you you can uh just
like in spectrograph theory sometimes
you don't want to work with the
adjacency matrix you want to work with
the normalized adjacency matrix okay
and the normalized adjacency matrix can
be
just as almost as easily extended to
tensors right for hyper graphs right the
the thing is that you need a k minus one
factorial that becomes one when k is 2
and instead of the square root of
d i d j you need the well you know the
geometric mean of the product of the
degrees of your vertices okay so this is
when k is equals to 2 this reduces to
your usual normalized uh adjacency
matrix and of course you once you have
this you can define normalized
hypergraph laplacian and stuff like this
this was actually started by my postdoc
and his phd thesis
okay
well so the thing is uh what is this but
you know again you know if you view
graph theory as a
as discrete differential geometry if you
view a graph as a as a discrete analog
of your
riemann a reminding manifold and this is
actually you know the uh
the analog of actually uh you
using you know you know the graph la
passion is uh elizon manifold uh or
rather the manifold laplacian is going
to be given by this right if you look at
this this actually defines the manifold
plus and this is sort of your core
boundary operator
well on a graph when everything becomes
discrete this gives you the
about the square of f i f j right the
finite difference thing that we were
talking about earlier the graph now if
you raise this instead well this is
still the two noun but if you raise this
to the p p power okay the two norm to
the p power
okay uh
then
the discrete analog of this thing okay
on the manifold i don't know whether
it's been studied in many form maybe it
is okay gives you actually the uh
it gives you this okay gives you the uh
the normalized hyper graph laplacian
yeah so it's sort of the
discrete version of what you would
expect on a what looks pretty natural on
a manifold right except that this of
course the how do you define the the
gradient of a of a full uh
well uh
of a let's say for instance of a four
sim a three simplex okay it's it's
actually the finite difference uh uh
definition okay so uh i guess i'm out of
time well so anyway the uh
i ran off
i couldn't finish my slide so this is
where i i stopped so uh the result that
we need for to find at the to find the
eigenvalues of a hypergraph of a
permanent hyper of the permanent is
based on this one okay this is a very
basic result in spectrograph theory that
says if the graph is bipartite you can
split it into two sets with edges only
running from one to the other then the
uh the spectrum okay all the eigenvalues
must be symmetric okay
precisely this well there's this analog
for hypergraph okay it's uh
actually my phd thesis but i didn't
publish it but it's been published by
joshua cooper and his quota and the the
observation is that permanent hypograph
is an empire hypograph again using this
this relation and then what uh shanghau
and i did was that we wrote down
actually equations that characterized
when this this would this would hold
right and uh certain other things and
with that you can actually find the
eigenvalues of your permanent okay
thank you
question
can you find the eigenvec eigenvector of
determinant
also for
normal oh altenew i do not know but the
eigenvector
so the eigenvector of your permanent
tensor right
are precisely your permutation matrices
okay so you think of the
uh
so let's say i look at this uh
this thing okay the permanent
tensor is the eigenvectors of this are
precisely uh well depending on how you
view this right you know uh
let's say well in a concrete way you
take any permutation matrix and stack
all the columns you get a matrix of uh
dimension n squared that would be an
eigenvector of your permanent
right and for the determinant
uh the same almost the same okay but the
eigenvalues are different you can also
write down you can also ask the same
question for the determinant yeah but
that's a bit trickier okay because
that's uh you have to do something
before it becomes a
it becomes before it becomes this one is
automatically an adjacency tensor on the
you know of a hypergraph for determinant
because it's minus sign right there's a
sign in there so you need to do
something before it becomes an adjacency
tensor of some type of graph um yeah
oh yes you deliver can you say more
about your solver your multiplexing
solver i didn't understand the
hypothesis oh okay so the thing is that
isn't one yet
so if we want to do this i guess uh is
that is that an actual implementation of
this human thing but i didn't understand
the hypothesis okay so it's it's the
it's the same so what i was suggesting
was that you know
if you want to get rid of this condition
right so essentially this this is by
representing a matrix a right that is
symmetric wiggly diagonally dominant as
a graph laplacian roughly speaking
that's how i guess they did it right uh
but if you want to get rid of that
condition let's say you want to get rid
of the diagonally dominant condition how
can you do it so one way is to instead
of looking at
graph laplacian which is always going to
be positive uh
definite you can look at higher order
laplacians which would not have that
property so it's simple just you have uh
the simple case would be the graph only
has triangles and edges yeah
and uh there's some condition here about
what the graph has to the property uh so
what i'm thinking is that right
yes if if you want to solve the one
laplacian one way is to use the
screaming tank algorithm
this is your first definition not that
no yeah this is this is this is the no
no this is the precisely this definition
okay
this this one okay
this one okay if you want to solve this
equation
on a graph okay you want to invert this
operator on a graph in nearly linear
time you can do it if that graph has
non-negative rigid curvature according
to that definition deny the problem we
have how do you simply find the flow on
the edges that meets the demand
i mean if when you work it out
you need to be able to find you know a
circulation that meets the demand a
circulation demand
how did you just find that let alone
you know this this i didn't do it okay
it's uh sort of uh it's nice i'm
discussing with uh uh collaborators as
cheyenne and and
but i actually haven't done this it's
just that you know based on this is sort
of i can't tell you why this is true
okay
if the
combinatorial rigid curvature is
non-negative
then the graph helmholtzian okay this
one laplacian is going to be
diagonally dominant and of course by
it's symmetric by definition and
therefore you can use human trying to
solve it in nearly linear time okay so
we do know that but in general without
this condition then i do not know this
is all i'm saying you know i actually
haven't tried this at all guys have a
solver for one of the blessings sorry
you guys have a solver for one of the
players in a special case where we have
a three-dimensional symphysial complex
that's convex
but i don't know
but in general i don't even know how you
find quote a flux
that meets the meets a given demand on
the edges right
uh huh
you know you're assigning
the triangles yeah and you want that to
induce a curl on the
on the edges yeah
so you can sort of at the end prove that
you need to find one of mine energy i
see so i i have to confess
when you get all done but we don't know
how to find just the first block just
any flow okay so then the special case
where it's collapsible
so i'm uh i've confessed that i've
really not looked into this at all so
it's it's just a uh you know i want to
say something that sort of of maybe some
relevance to the workshop people and
that's that's only only reason i talk
about this but it's it's not uh but you
know someone else's work no no it's
something that we talk about uh cheyenne
and uh and uh johan and i talk about
this now we're gonna write a proposal on
this and if it's funded then we'll
definitely have plenty of money and time
for people to hire to move on
yes something that we would like to do
yes
it's this algorithm okay let's say that
is an algorithm right and spumen tanks
prove that there is such an algorithm
that if i give you a diagonally dominant
symmetric matrix i can invert it in
nearly linear time right you agree right
well you can solve them right yeah in
this case
this matrix delta one is going to be
diagonally dominant if the reaching
curvature of the graph is non-negative
so you can solve it and really now
that's what i'm saying uh exactly how to
do it in fact i i don't even know how to
do this to be frank
i just roughly
gary does know how to do it okay okay
all right